[Music]
you
you
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb Denby
and I'll be your driver on this on this
road today's topic is a little bit more
fun a little bit more light than a lot
of a road to to thousands have been
usually it's like heavy stuff like this
is how to calculate and you should train
like this or something like that today I
wanted to go over swindles and of course
this is a lot a lot of fun it's one of
my favorite parts of chess is losing all
game and you know feeling badly and then
all of a sudden you find that tactical
shot or that trick that gets you back
into the game so I wanted to start off
with a couple swindles that happened
just from some online games I've played
with in actually the past week this kind
of happens all the time online and it's
where you'll find most of your swindles
working the best and then I wanted to go
to some actual over the board games I
had played and see how it can actually
impact at a little bit of a higher level
and then we're gonna take a look finally
at the highest level of chess some games
between the world's best players and see
how even they can can still get swindled
and how it can happen in your games as
well so this first game I want to go
through pretty quickly it was just a
blitz game online I had the white pieces
here and I found myself in this end game
so I found a little tactic here to take
the e5 pawn black takes my d6 pawn and
after 93 black chose to play Bishop c4
and I went in for this kind of tactic
that gets us into this singular Knight
endgame so what do you think's going on
here who would you rather be white or
black
yeah we've got a super far advanced pawn
if we're the white pieces but is this a
benefit or or a bad thing can black take
advantage of it and make it a weakness
so yeah it can be a huge benefit it kind
of ties up the black pieces in this case
though it's a little bit far from our
pieces so if we're not careful black is
simply gonna play King f8 King e8 and
King d7 and capture our pawn you can
also add in this Knight as another
attacker after he brings the King in and
this one might just fall so as white I
was actually a little bit nervous here
and I think black should be doing pretty
well in this endgame so the idea I came
up with was to simply place this knight
on to f5 and to try to hold this pawn
and attack some of some of blacks
weaknesses as well he's simply he's
simply played Knight to g8 just kind of
an odd looking move to defend the H pawn
and this is kind of where he started
going wrong I think I just brought my
King into the game King d4 King e6 and
this is where I kind of had to make a
decision so in your games if you think
you're a little bit worse off this works
best at obviously fast time controls you
need something to you know generate some
swindles to generate some tricks to
generate some ideas you need some kind
of advantage and a lot of the games that
we look at the advantage is gonna be
that the opponent's king is weak
obviously that can't really work here
it's tough to have a weak King when
there's just a knight on the board but
in this case I have a different type of
advantage my advantage is this really
far advanced pawn and while black is
attacking it if I give up this advantage
then there's really nothing for me to
play for right if I give up my d6 pawn I
mean how how am I ever gonna win the
game black is going to be advancing
these pawns pretty quickly and he has a
pawn majority on the Queen side in this
Knight is really close to really making
some threats on my Kings side so I
decided how am I gonna win the game if I
don't have this d6 pawn so I came up
with a pretty fancy way to try to keep
it do you guys see any ideas on how to
hold this pawn
so obviously the problem is our Knights
attacked and if we move the knight and
the pawn Falls immediately so we need
something a bit better ca your your
along the right direction here we want
to bring our King in this way but we
can't give up the knight just yet
because this idea doesn't work because
the Black Knight is here to defense
however if the Black Knight were to be
drawn to some other Square and then this
idea would be working internet would be
untouchable so is there any way we can
combine those ideas
yeah g4 is exactly right we solidify our
Knight for a moment black captures this
pawn and we capture back and after
Knight takes g4 kind of accepting our
sacrifice I played king c5 so I'm
risking a lot here but you always kind
of have to do when swindling
opportunities arise so of course black
can't capture this because the pawn will
promote my opponent is a good enough
player to realize this but he simply
just captures my last pawn and so now
I've got some trouble to worry about
right I've got problem number one in
problem number two and I had better find
something to make up for it so I've got
my one advantage over here and I decide
to go all-in and try to take this this
other pawn on b7
the black King retreats which is pretty
natural he just wants to blockade the
pawn I go ahead and capture he starts
bringing back his Knight to defend
against my pawn and he does so
successfully and actually black is
probably just winning here but of course
it's a blitz game the players are low on
time so I shuffle back and forth and
since my opponent thinks he's winning he
tries to win which trying to win is a
great way to lose a chess game and
trying to lose can sometimes be a way to
win so he gives up to c6 pawn trying to
advance his
his queen or king side ponds which this
should still be fine for black but at
this point white probably has enough for
a draw because the King had left c6 and
I can kind of kick this night around for
eternity and he can't ever really leave
without letting me Queen he came up with
f4 I played Knight h5 f3 King bee 7f -
the knight back to g3 I had to stop the
Queen we danced around with the Knights
for a couple moves I finally played king
c7 doing things a little bit differently
and after this the knight really is
having a tough time getting back to stop
this pawn he comes up with King d7
sacrificing the night maybe a bit better
was this move but at this point he was
very low on time so what do you think
the idea is here
[Music]
so yeah if we push and what was blacks
idea and that night c8 so usually the
night is enough to kind of stop stop
this pawn some ways somehow but of
course my opponents long time he just
brings the King back and eventually we
get here and what do you think's going
on here should white win or it should
black draw us somehow
I would think like it's family by
promoting on c1 so f1 yeah right so this
isn't this is one ideas but I can try to
do this well if white doesn't take it
then yeah a queen might be coming but
you're on the right track so one thing's
for certain
this black king isn't going anywhere
unless we let it out so does anybody see
any potential checkmates for a white so
where it starts getting fun
I'll give you a hint here white is
actually completely winning so you can
imagine the night landing here right so
you can imagine it you can find some way
for this night to get here
some paths how do you get there it's
really tough right it takes a lot of
moves mm-hmm so the problem is as soon
as you step here it's over it's over
let's see
imagine some knight to f12 III to d5 to
c7 right so all in all what if we do it
right away then black can probably just
play g3 and this looks like a problem if
we take Queens and then it's enough for
a job like you were saying so it turns
out the win here is to simply waste a
tempo force black to Queen it's the only
move and you ignore this pawn and
believe it or not this is checkmate
so just to just to put the cherry on top
and prove its a real swindle I didn't
see any of this
I knew that 97 was checkmate and I was
like okay I'm gonna get my knight to c7
I don't care if I lose this game it's
worth trying and so I didn't see this
clever idea of wasting a tempo so I
simply played a night off one
immediately
he played g3 I played Knight e3 and now
my opponent had a chance to draw by
queening immediately however he didn't
really sense the danger and you wanted
to try to win so he wanted to play g2
which is of course losing to the same
trick so I did end up winning in the
ends not quite as it was intended but
say yeah so that was just like a fun
swindle that happened happened just
within this last week and so what was
the point of all this of looking at this
well for one it's a lot of fun and
number two is it really introduces this
idea
if you want to win a game where you
think you're behind and you think you're
like a better player than your opponent
you really think you okay I have to win
this game you have to leave yourself
with something you have to have some
something to play it for at least one
thing in this case it was first my deep
on and then my a pawn if you don't have
this one thing you can really play it
for to pressure your opponent you're not
gonna find any like fancy swindles or
anything like that your opponent my
blunder something if you get really
really lucky and luck definitely plays a
huge part in any swindle but it's very
very unlikely that you'll find something
I'm gonna jump right to another one of
my swindles so this one was played
against Jonathan schranz who as you may
remember I played a huge match with a
couple months ago and this was the one
that kind of turned the tide of the
match it put me in the lead and I won
the next game pretty quickly so here I
had the white pieces
I played b4 completely missing that
night b3 forks my queen and my rook and
so uh now I'm just totally lost but
that's okay you have to be losing in
order to pull off a swindle so just the
first step is lose the game before you
can win it so black is totally winning
here he's up the exchange he's got a lot
of pressure on second rank he's got
pressure in my deep pawn his queen is
gonna find a path in after I have to
deal with this pawn things are bad okay
you just have to keep playing moves in
this situation so I moved my Bishop to
b2 trying to relieve some of this
pressure I come up with a one move
tactic which thankfully pays off I take
make event I take advantage of this pin
but that's okay like still completely
winning and then you know I the reason I
played like this wasn't so much that I
could win upon because the pawn wasn't
very important like my pawn is hanging
the Queen can just come in to checkmate
me but I saw that I had a trick here I
saw that my opponent's King had been
left a little bit weak and if he thought
my idea was just to win upon
then I could kind of execute this trick
so in the game black played Queen c2 who
can find the swindle does anybody see it
it's a - movie and then what's the point
so yeah it's check what will black do
yeah and that's just checkmate the ship
DS d5 King h8 check man you can also try
your rook f7 and I could take this but
there's also actually just checkmate in
one and so I won this game like this so
once again when things are bad if you
see an idea a tactical idea you have
something to play for you should try it
because I mean the worst that happens is
they see it and then you're still losing
which you were losing in the first place
so this was also a blitz game though so
you might be saying well okay I mean
this works in fast time controlled chess
but I mean come on let's see some real
real-life examples so now I wanted to go
over this game which was a classical
time control that I played against
Jonathan Israel who is a chess
instructor here at the club I think he's
around the 8 1,800 level and so this one
wasn't so much a direct swindle where I
was totally dead lost and I found
someone move trick to come back into the
game but it was more of a kind of a
dirty game you know what I mean it's
like okay I want to checkmate this guy I
want to get out of here I want to win
the staff staff championship so let's
see how it went he played the old benoni
which is signified after this move kind
of a 5d 6d v and e5 the structure is the
idea I played Bishop b2 Bishop e3
a six a four I want to stop this b5 idea
and here I decide to go for h3 so what
do you think the point of h3 is
there are a few points
so this is the big point is it controls
g4 it stops the Bishop from coming here
almost more importantly it can stop a
knight from coming here so if you were
to play like rook b8 and I play Knight
f3 now there's no Knight g4 attacking my
Bishop because my pawn controls it I
also had more devious intentions though
after Knight f8 which is what was played
I played g4 so this is a good way to set
yourself up for kind of an easy attack
when the center is closed like this very
often both players will keep their kings
in the center or you know though Castle
queenside but the point is it's not
entirely important to castle that King
with the center so closed so I just
wanted to kind of attack my opponent in
kind of a crude way and see what I could
make of it some idea is I just want to
push these pawns up the board and gain a
lot of space on the Kings side where my
bishops point and then hopefully
generate an attack on the King from
there he played very calmly he played h6
i continued with age for my plan he
played knight h7 putting a lot of
attackers on g5 and attacking this h4
pawn so if you're the player with the
white pieces here what do you want to do
it'll give you a couple options you can
play h5 defending your pawn from this
threat you can play g5 sacrificing this
pawn after something like takes and
takes or you can ignore it you can play
something like Knight f3
what do you think
you like nine of three okay knight of
three was a bit of a red herring there's
a problem with it it loses this pawn if
I could play Knight f3 that'd be great
but leaves g4 behind the big two options
are h5 or g5 which one do you think I
should go for g5 so why is that
the one
that night
mm-hmm so we can play a pawn takes and
pawn takes and the really good benefit
to this is it opens up our rook the bad
news is that it is a pawn sacrifice
black and just went upon so if h5
doesn't really give up anything
why don't we want to play it what's the
problem with h5
so we're blocking off and you know some
of our ideas but it gives up a very
important square it gives up g5 so this
Bishop is kind of not so great for black
but now he can simply bring it to g5
I'll be forced to kind of allow this
trade and his Knights can kind of
untangle themselves right the spawns
gonna be a bit weak I have some f4 ideas
still but I don't really trust them so
h5 is bad because it gives up this g5
square and it keeps everything closed so
I don't for g5 giving up a pond and
going for some swindles Queen d2 he
plays rook g8 so he wanted to step out
of this pen which makes a lot of sense
I play Knight f3 you need all your
pieces in the attack Knight f6 Knight g5
may g6 king d2 Knight g4 I have to take
this he takes this and simply your g1
the bishop comes back to d7 and let's
pause for a moment here so which side
would you rather be white or black
I think white looks a little better
white looks a little better
yeah definitely white is a little bit
more active right now especially with
the rooks in this night but what does
black have going for him like has some
significant advantages as well
so the first one is obvious Black's up
upon right this pawn doesn't mean a lot
right now but down the road you know
this pawn is is gonna mean a lot but a
lot more important than that is this
pieces have some squares this bishops
eyeing this a pawn and he's probably
gonna play b5 soon opening up this rook
where can this night go tonight has a
very nice square yeah this f4 square
looks very very nice for this Knight if
this night lands on f4 it's gonna be
blocking off my queen for my knight and
it's gonna be kind of really in my way
one more advantage for white is this
King is a little bit loose but all in
all I think black actually stands better
here largely thanks to this you know
hero Knight that can jump into f4 and
also thanks to the extra pawn but as
white as the higher rate of player in
this event you really don't want to just
like give up on your attack because of
that you always want to be playing for
counter play playing for threats and
really bringing all of your pieces into
the attack and more often than not if
you do something like this just continue
playing naturally continue playing
threatening looking moves your opponents
are either gonna believe your threats
and give up a lot or they're gonna miss
something and that's what happened in
this game so simply your h7 bring the
rook in Queen f6 I brought my Knight to
e2 so you got to use all the pieces in
the attack Bishop a4
so black kind of takes another pawn
which maybe isn't what black should be
doing right now you know kind of got to
sort out your King before you go
grabbing even more I play Knight g3 and
then black plays a very natural move and
he also plays a losing move so what
would you play with black here what
moves come to mind
keep in mind I'm threatening to do stuff
like this if this guy stuff like this
and hit both of these guys some
dangerous things so yeah that's a
natural idea you want to trade off the
Queens any other ideas
do you think what would you play
any ideas
that's okay so b5 I wouldn't be so ready
to do it's a nice idea it does kind of
block off this Bishop so technically
it's it's not great and also I might
want to put my king over there because
it's starting to look pretty dangerous
on this side of the board so that's kind
of my bailout is I want to Castle
queenside and have at least this pawn
for protection so yeah I thought okay
you might try to Castle queenside or
something he might play Queen uh for the
move I was really worried about was
Knight f4 so once again black should
seek counter play here rather than
passively defending that's how you kind
of start to get into territory where it
it gets very dangerous for you and you
start getting swindled you want to kind
of defend actively you want to make your
own threats and pose white some problems
so I would love to play Knight f5 here
but I think tactically there's just this
move Knight d5 and if I were to take now
my knight is undefended so now that for
would have given me a lot of problems
and I think black would be winning in
this position instead he went for the
natural queen f4 thinking if you could
just trade Queens all those problems
would be solved but this is not so much
not so true because I've got four other
pieces left and his pieces are quite
scattered kind of across the board so
you know I just have to activate my
pieces played Knight f5 you played York
d8 trying to defend this pawn this gives
up on g7
and pretty quickly after this more pawns
fell some tactics came and this is
simply over for black and he resigned in
this position so it's up to you if you
want to classify this as a swindle but
it just really shows the importance of
piece activity and finding making
threats finding something to play
against right as long as you have some
kind of plan something to play against
if your opponent doesn't find a plan
more often than not you're going to win
it doesn't matter if your plan is the
wrong plan if your plans kind of dumb
and shouldn't work if you're at least
playing towards one idea and you're
opponent isn't more often than not your
one idea is going to be the decider and
that's kind of what happened here I came
up with a horrible plan of pushing my
Kings side pawns and making threats on
that side of the board and this plan
shouldn't work and this plan is pretty
bad for white but in the end my opponent
didn't come up with the plan he started
playing moves on the Kings side he
traded off these Knights then he his
pieces at the Queen side and played
Bishop takes a 4 and then he said let's
just trade the Queens and kind of
consolidate and this is kind of jumping
across the board like this is what led
to him just kind of losing so even in
swindles you have to be playing for a
plan playing for an idea ok that's
enough of my stupid games though why
don't we take a look at swindler
extraordinaire Kaoru Nakamura and
unlikely swindler Magnus Carlsen it's
not very often that you see Magnus
Carlsen in a worse position but it
happened here and Magnus really really
really hooked snack Ameri really
swindled them in this game so I don't
know if you guys remember familiar with
this but for a long time
Nakamura had an awful score against
Magnus Nakamura was like the number two
player in the world number three player
in the world very solidly the number one
player in the US but he had lost
something like seven games against
Carlsen they had a number of draws but
Hikaru had never won a game and this was
this game was back in 2014 and this was
during that era when Hikaru just
couldn't seem to get it done against
Magnus and so whether it be
psychological problems the Nakamura was
dealing with with this you know
unbeatable guy that he just can't can't
checkmate as well as just Magnus being a
very slippery kind of guy very difficult
guide to to beat it led to Nakamura his
downfall in this game so the game
started off in an opening I've covered
here before in an f3 NIMS Oh Magnus
played d5 and we got a very interesting
line where white gets a huge center and
black gets to play for some dark squares
and that's really all blacks going to be
playing for it's the dark squares Magnus
bar the bishop back to c5 bishop came to
g7 or g5 rather both players kind of get
developed Pocari ops to Castle queenside
and Bishop d4 these moves are kind of
okay for Magnus but already is in some
trouble why it's simply going to attack
on the Kings side black decides he
should try to attack on the Queen side
but in reality after a couple whoops
running out of power Ben is on the hunt
for a power cord pretty soon but okay
what was I saying
blacks already in some trouble here he
made a couple inaccurate moves this a5
and a6 idea to activate this rook wasn't
really the most accurate and white is
already kind of just winning and winning
pretty easily what simply plays Knight
g3 by bringing his knight into the
attack we see g6 trying to keep this
night out of some key squares white
continues with h4 and in black plays AF
for Rick h2 it's a very nice move to
defend laterally the Queen comes out to
a5 we see the bishop drop back to D to
get getting out of the way of the Jeep
on and after h5 rook b6 Bishop c1 you
can really see how a whites attack just
seems to be coming through a lot faster
black does capture on b2 a momentary
peace sacrifice but in this position you
can kind of see see what happens so for
the moment white is up a piece flex
going to regain this piece on b2 but
it's not going to be enough to kind of
stop White's attack so this is so far
was a brilliantly played game by
Nakamura he's totally winning in this
position if I flip on the engine it says
yeah plus five plus six plus twelve
whatever you want
not Nakamura is the best the game's over
but that's that's not how it happened
as you can see so it started off with
rift xb2
this move makes sense Nakamura found the
accurate King a 1 just stepping out of
it of course would be a huge mistake to
capture this rook as you'd get
checkmated and one move so there's still
some tricks here but not Camaro steps
out of them rook takes age 2r it takes
age to queen g6 Knight f5 rook e8 queen
g4 Queen b6 Queen h3 Queen g6 they're
kind of shuffling a little bit here I've
got the power cord coming in with the
save all right and then here is
Nakamura's kind of critical mistake so
how should you approach positions like
this black really can't do anything
right this rook can't move if this work
steps out of the way let's just say
white passes if this work steps out of
the way black gets hit with this 97
check which is killer
if this Queen steps out of the way takes
on g5 for example you get checkmated in
one move so these two pieces can't move
that's that's first off secondly okay
maybe this Knight can move but what do
you do with it right I'm you come to b6
this doesn't do anything you come to a5
this doesn't do anything you threaten
one check but of course it's not going
to help you you can push this pawn but
again it's really not going to help your
situation here so nakamura has all the
time in the world and what he did was
rush things so of course when your
opponent can't move there's absolutely
no need to rush right you just want to
make sure everything is locked down you
keep your opponent out of the game and
you avoid all counter play however the
move he did allows black away back into
the game already white is still better
but after this next move it's going to
be a lot trickier to to win the game so
what do you think Magnus came up with
what's his one thing that he should be
playing for you know in that first game
that I showed my one thing was I had a
pawn on d6 and then upon on the a file
that I wanted to promote in that game
against Jonathan I saw one tactic one
trick that I could play for and I played
for it
so what's Magnus is one thing going to
be
[Music]
got three pawns against one yeah he's
got a lot of pawns so maybe in some
endgame he can try to push these that's
something to play for but more important
than that White has a problem
so all these pieces are great this piece
is awesome and this piece is awesome
this piece is awesome this piece is not
awesome White's attack has broken
through and White's attack was much
faster in this game but blacks attack
did some damage as well got rid of two
of these key defenders two of these
pawns in front of the White King and
left a lot of open space back there so
Magnus is one thing that he wants to
play for is he wants to make some
threats against White's King so how on
earth are you going to achieve that from
this position so step one is finding
some way for these two pieces to start
playing so how did Magnus open up a file
to get these two pieces in the game
what could he have done
first of all whites making a lot of
threats here you for one who's gonna
play 97 next turn if you don't stop them
exactly Knight takes d6 now this is
actually a peace sacrifice if you notice
after Knight takes D 6 Queen takes d6 is
not very good
due to checkmate which we've seen this
before we said you know this Queen can't
move this trick can't move but now that
the knight has been drawn to d6 the
black rook actually can move because
there's no 97 threat so this lets black
play let's see my arrow keys stopped
working this lets black play rook d8
all of a sudden we see a pathway a
pathway to this King right so it has to
be careful white plays Knight c4 but all
of a sudden Queen takes e4 and we've got
a lot of pathways into this King right a
lot of threats to look out for a lot of
open lines and not a lot of pieces
defending the white King and so already
black is equalized here and if white
isn't very very careful he's just gonna
get checkmated which is some way to what
happened in the game white went with
queen h5 trying to keep an eye on this
diagonal black simply plays rook d3
after Ric h4 Queen f5 keeping an eye on
this the Queen comes back to e2 so all
of a sudden we see the black the white
piece is coming back back back back and
the black piece is going forward forward
forward and I can kind of tell you the
the tide of the game which way this game
is turning the black king is getting
safer the White King is getting less
safe
so now be 5 so Magnus brings these pawns
into action Knight d2 this allows Queen
takes g5 in the sin game
and in the send game black is simply
dominating he's got one two three four
five pawns in exchange for one night and
really you need about three pawns for it
to be considered equal and so very
quickly this game actually just ended in
disaster this H pawn simply comes down
the board and then this e pawn comes
down the board and then here Hikaru
actually just resigned so from plus a
billion crushing position to resigning
just completely lost endgame fairly
quickly um so this this was a pretty
famous game a pretty famous swindle and
it really it took Hikaru another I think
like two or three years before he
managed to score win against Magnus so
he would have loved to get this one back
and so as always giving these miraculous
ways back into the game it's all about
playing for one thing whether it be a
weakness in the opponent's camp a weak
King or just even a simple tactical idea
that you see and you think your opponent
might miss you need something to play
for now I think I'm gonna look at what
might be the most famous swindle of all
time I think they called it something
like the swindle of the century on some
website that I found it on so this game
was between Alexander beli offski and
Larry Marc Christiansen Larry
Christiansen of course one of the u.s.
chess greats world-class player back in
his day and he played quite quite a lot
of good games this wasn't one of them
but this however was one of the greatest
swindles
yeah so keep an eye out for Larry
starting July 10th we'll be here in st.
Louis playing the u.s. Senior
Championship so get to see him back in
action this game was eventually I
believe the Kings Indian defense after
some maneuvering so who's familiar with
this this opening have you guys seen
something like this before
No okay well quickly I'll explain some
ideas White has a huge Center and he
wants to use this Center to expand on
the queenside he wants to use this
c-pawn as his mobile kind of pawn lever
and he wants to win on the queenside and
meanwhile black's idea is usually to
either break down the center somehow
sometimes by putting a knight on c5 and
playing f5 or more commonly he wants to
checkmate white using f5f 4G 5g four and
really just throwing everything at white
to try and win and so let's see this
battle of ideas and how it plays out in
this game we see 97 bringing this knight
to c5 perhaps but now simply b4 so in
this specific variation that we got
white seems to be in time to kind of
stop blacks ideas before he gets there
so a5 is natural trying to break down
White's defense of this square so once
again I'll ask you two options should
you play something like b5 or something
like a three which one looks more
natural
one of these has a huge positional
mistake
game-ending mistake a 3 or B 5
neither the look game ending but the
kind of can be you want to play a 3 yes
so a 3 is totally right
what's wrong with B 5 it's anybody know
has to do with this battle of ideas that
I just talked about
so in general interests the site where
you have more space you want to maneuver
your pieces over there and then kind of
rip it open because once you open it up
your opponent's pieces aren't gonna be
well placed because he had less space to
move around in it so you can kind of
picture Weiss rooks easily coming here
White's Bishop maybe dropping back
looking at some squares the White Queen
looking at some more squares this Knight
is already well placed for the Queen
side whereas blacks pieces this Queens a
little shut out by his own Knight or her
own Knight these works can come over but
they're just staring at their own pawns
this Knight is nowhere near the Queen
side so white wants to open things up on
the Queen side eventually that's what
I'm trying to say
and with b5 he's locking it down
permanently black will play a very
natural move like b6 white can continue
pretty much any way he likes we'll just
make some some move and now after Knight
c5 white really has a strong hold on the
c5 square you can attack White's Center
and white can't really do anything about
it so b5 is like a horrible positional
move you never really want to close the
position on the side where you have more
space so a3 was played this keeps the
threat of the pawn on c5 so the knight
can't jump there and eventually White's
plan to open it up is going to be to
push this pawn forward so we see Rick a6
another kind of instance where Rick a6
isn't the greatest move it's meant by
Knight b5 hitting blacks weakness Knight
b6 defending it with the Queen
we see rook c1 again preparing this idea
of c5 take sticks Queen d7 Queen d3 rook
a for Queen b3 ok 8 white is just
preparing himself for this idea of
opening it up with c5 and we see black
making some moves on the Kings side but
you can kind of tell he's nowhere near
achieving his plan he's not gonna find
some checkmate with just a queen over
here White has kind of succeeded already
by making black play on the side of the
board where black has less space so
Queen c7 blacks kind of just maneuvering
around c6 and now finally white breaks
through with c5 so we see once again
kind of the black pieces
okay maybe these rooks are active on the
a file but this Knight is a little out
in the middle of nowhere on g4 and this
night on b6 isn't very happy either
meanwhile White's Knight wants to jump
into d6 both of whites rooks are well
placed and the bishop makes threats both
on this night and on the Queen side so
already I think white is just completely
crushing here white won the battle of
ideas he got to play on the side where
he had more space generate threats on
that side well black couldn't really do
anything about it
we saw upon tix and pawn takes of course
the tactical idea is if you take this
guy I'll take this guy and I'll likely
win this and even if I don't this pawn
is going to be very very strong
especially with these jerks coming down
so we saw Knight d7 instead this Knight
does come to the d6 square they back to
f6 and Bishop c4
and night takes up two so this is where
the swindles kind of start so I'm sure
Larry Christiansen was sitting back
looking at this position entirely
unhappy and said okay I need something
to play for so what is blacks think that
he can play for here there's no real
weaknesses in the white camp maybe say
e4 is weak but it's pretty easily
defended both by this night and you know
even if necessary a rook or a queen king
of back to defend it maybe a c5 is gonna
be weak but it's also pretty well
defended by the rook already and this
Knight stops this Queen from interacting
with it so what's black going to play
for does anybody have any ideas what can
black play for
right now it looks like nothing
so I already showed the next move
accidentally I went a bit too far
he played Knight takes f2 so of course
what does this tell you black wants to
play for not a draw specifically what's
his weakness what's White's weakness
that he wants to play against so he has
more pawns but Knight 6 f2 is a very
very direct move it's saying what what
does black want to do you don't give up
a piece for a pawn to say ok now I have
more pawns it's an imbalance but not a
favorable one
the game takes the night
okay so you're talking in specifics
generally what is black playing against
after Knight takes F - it's similar to
what Magnus did against Hikaru give up
his knight in order to do what in order
to get where - this King right
so black created something to play
against in this position the white king
is very well defended g3 is defended by
this pawn this file is closed because
the pawn is there you can easily defend
it with either rook but after Knight
takes f2 this King is looking a little
bit airy a little loose there's ideas of
rook a3 hitting this pawn indirectly
through the Queen his ideas of Knight g4
and Queen f6 coming towards this King
and - you know Larry probably thought
okay maybe I can do something with all
of these ideas unfortunately for him
he's totally dead lost here
this is totally dead he just gave up a
night for a pond which is horrible it's
awful white should never lose this game
and if in fact you know after you're
okay three white simply captures on f7
with check the King has to move and
white plays Queen e6
so no Alexander Bella offski I'm I'm you
know of course I have no idea what
actually happened but I like to imagine
in my editorial ization that a belly
offski sat back like okay come on Larry
resign come on you're down a piece my
King might be weak but your King is much
weaker than my King will ever be I've
got two rooks on the back rank I'm
offering a queen trade if we trade the
Queen's like you're just you're down a
piece you're down a full piece you don't
even have a pawn for it so he's probably
sitting there an indignant and insulted
and Larry's like okay I'll give you a
check the King runs away it's like okay
I'll bring in my other rook try to get
something going and now probably
belly-up skis should have started
sensing some danger
so first of all what happens if white
takes this free Queen yeah all of a
sudden we see a draw so Larry's not
without ideas here Rick a3 was a very
very clever move to delay having to deal
with this Queen so this is a draw and
it's actually a draw by perpetual check
and the reason for that is the king can
never step up so it's confined to moving
side to side and a rook has access to
all of these squares so this would be a
draw but okay I mean Belyaev ski is like
come on dude I'm one of the world's best
grandmasters I'm not going to play Queen
takes Queen who do you think I am this
is an obvious trick plays ninety eight
check and says haha what are you gonna
do now King age six is played running
away once again you can imagine Queen
takes Queen it's the same idea
however Knight takes Knight is a little
bit better that's saying okay I have the
h3 square under control if you go for
this same idea I simply play King h1
there's no more checks if you take my
queen I still control this square it's
two pieces now Larry how many pieces is
it going to take before you give it up
so okay I mean Larry just plays rook
takes g3 King h1 we see this idea on the
board plays Queen takes f7 so this idea
is the same idea we've just seen right
so what happens after Queen takes Queen
it's the same idea same perpetual draw
Larry's got one idea and he's sticking
with it so Queen takes Queen once again
belli offski is like come on dude rook
d7 this is checkmate what's wrong with
you let's go home I'm done playing chess
Larry played Queen takes Knight and you
know beli offski I'm sure was just like
okay finally he's giving it up just
Queen takes Queen the game's over and
then he was shocked he was appalled at
blacks next move
what do you think happens find the draw
we tried the same idea it doesn't quite
work right King can come here we can
take
be a check
this one yeah you're on the right track
you're on the right track well you don't
have time to put put a rook here it's
checkmate no matter which rookie is
checkmate you need something immediate
I've been Simon thinks he has the answer
she won take it hmm so he's saying now
Ritchie to daring you to take this is
stalemate the Jeep on was mentioned but
the Jeep on is pinned to the king
however if you do things like this if I
run away if you track me here you got to
be careful cuz can take like this and
then the Jeep on can move if you check
me here once again I'm gonna start
running and maybe you can check me for a
while but someday some glorious day I
will find the comfort hold on I'm not
doing a very good job here hmm
what on earth I'm in this this is more
tricky than I gave it credit for so
there's a simpler way to arrive at the
same kind of thing but this is this is
pretty tricky here all right I refuse to
believe that this is all so dry I'll
look at that in a second but uh okay
what's the easier way so you've noticed
now that giving up both these rooks in
this position would be stalemate so
there's a much easier way where the
white king can't escape the white king
is nowhere to go
so this move was tried
what else is there well you think about
that I'll try to find a way to win hey
rook h2 is is the easier way so now of
course the white king is confined to the
age file and eventually you will be
forced to capture and so after rook h2
the game was agreed to be drawn and I
can only imagine how furious
Alexander Belyaev ski was after this one
but let's take another look at this
because this is interesting
so rook G to check King F 1 FG 1 check
is the only move and how do I escape how
do I escape
maybe I don't escape well that'd be
crazy
this was also a draw hmm I don't know do
you guys have any idea Turkey one I
don't know what can be done maybe this
is also drunk let's take a look no it's
definitely not drawn I was right the
first time you run you run
you keep running oh of course
C takes b6 allowing the C pawn to move
very well done so you have to go here
and the second step this way I can step
this way and finally I can take you once
my wreck disappears thread is no longer
there so that would have been a very
nice win for white but unfortunately
rook h2 exists in this game was a draw
so swindle of the century they said an
incredible game so it just goes to show
never get too confident in yourself even
if you're a world-class Grandmaster I'm
all right I think we have time to look
at one more swindle I felt bad about
what I did at Cara Nakamura earlier
showing showing is you know most painful
loss of his career against Magnus
Carlsen
so I here's one for him here's one for
him so Hikaru had the black pieces here
so what do you think's going on in the
Sun game who would you rather be white
or black Victor or Hikaru
it's a step one my step one at least in
evaluating positions so I like to count
the number of pieces so both players
have a rook what players have a bishop
White has this night for this rook
so why it's actually down the exchange
but he's got this pawn and he's got this
bone so all in all I'd rather be white
here a big reason for that is if black
does nothing this is going to happen and
there's no way to stop it
the bishop controls a7 the knight
controls these two squares and black
would be in a lot of trouble so king b2
was played in this case rook a rook HHH
one night to b8 and pretty quickly this
pawn is captured and so now white is
definitely just much better in fact
white is winning here not only does he
have this a pawn ready to go but he also
has this B pawn as well
so black tried to swindle own plays rook
c2 pretty innocuous move rook e1 check
King f3 and already white is in a lot of
danger simply rook a to a6
not really sensing the danger so what
does Black's think that he's going to
play against obviously he's already
started playing against it what's his
one idea his idea isn't really to stop
these pawns because we're beyond
stopping the puns
it's it's he's playing formate he's in
the classic hikaru style he's trying to
find some way to checkmate this king
before these pawns promote and I'll just
show it quickly the King comes to f5
bringing in his final piece there's a
knight check the King comes to e4 kind
of see that a box is being built the
king covers these three squares
Bishop covers some key squares and it's
already the King's in a box the question
is how do we tighten this box how do we
tighten the noose rook f3 is played
hoping for in exchange black does not
trade and after Bishop h4 the game is
already over
as you can see how quickly things can
kind of go wrong from this position
white is just much much better and I
think is simply winning here with this
King firmly placed in the center of the
board where it can be nice and safe all
he has to do is place something like
rook c3 black will have to move out of
the way we can come to c4 where all our
pieces are nice defenders we've got
pawns and pieces and we'll never get
checkmated instead of course king e4
simply running in the wrong direction
and once the white kings over here I
think it's just over you need these
pieces around your king so if this class
was nothing else we'll first let me show
the finish submission page for white
actually resigned of course the idea is
after King g4 the box is kind of sealed
after York g2 the only move is reck g3
and this is checkmate
so if nothing else let this class be a
cautionary tale okay if you find
yourself in a totally winning position
it's very very easy and it's happened to
countless players countless times it's
very easy to just turn your brain off
and say all right I've won this game
once I'm not gonna have to win it again
I've got everything I need to win the
game
I'm just gonna play natural moves and
get this over with go home take a take a
nap get this over with I've won this
game I don't know why he's not resigning
you can't play like that you've got to
be alert got to be aware of when your
opponent's going for these tricks and
you've got to be ready to stop them once
again when you're swindling I just a
quick review you need something to play
it for whether it be a passed pawn
whether it be a weakness whether it be
the weak King very often it is need
something to play for you should be
willing to give up a lot to play for it
even if it doesn't look like it works if
you're just playing for nothing and
you're just what letting your opponent
do whatever he wants to end the game
eventually your opponent will end the
game so always find counter play with
that of Mines any questions about
tonight's class anything at all any any
games you wanted to look at a little bit
more yep it's it's public already online
once again let me go over this quickly
if we can pull up the in the board maybe
if you want to find these studies just
go to lis chests go to studies in search
RT to K I put that on on all the studies
if you can see them all right here in
this case the one was swindlers paradise
and their pops right up and you can look
at all these games yourself with that in
mind thank you all for coming out thank
you YouTube audience for watching
hopefully this was an enjoyable one
there's a little bit more on the fun
side than serious chess see you next
time
you
you